Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. This is episode 51 of the podcast series. We have not long celebrated the 11-month which was on christmas eve in 2021 so we're fast approaching a whole year of this and it's been lovely being part of your world having you be part of my world and hearing all the lovely things you've said about the podcast i hope you find today useful and as ever if you do like the series please do leave me a review and leave me a rating on apple podcast it's so appreciated i know from looking at the stats recently that over 48 percent of you listen via spotify and that 38 percent of you listen via apple podcast which means 38 percent
of you could whilst you're listening to this show right now, head on to the app, click on show, and then very easily leave me a rating and just leave me a quick review whilst you're doing it as well. And you can do it whilst you're listening. There is no need to, you know, even break stride from whatever you're doing. Stay safe. Don't do it when you're driving. That is my firm advice, obviously. If you are watching on YouTube, it won't have missed your attention that I have suddenly got no headphones on. My headphones suddenly decided to stop working and I couldn't hear myself. But I've checked and the microphone is still working. So yeah, fingers crossed, this is all fine. So today's podcast episode was dreamed up
about 10 minutes ago by me because I was going to be doing a guest episode and it's been cancelled. And so I needed to come up with a plan for what to talk to you about. So I thought I would talk to you about some of the bits and pieces that I've been talking to people about on socials today, specifically LinkedIn, because you guys know I'm a big LinkedIn geek. If you're not already connected with me on there, do come over and find me. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. So today I was stopped in my tracks by a lovely status, a lovely post that Zahra Bilal had shared and she was talking about an Islamic principle that is the practice of Tawakkal. I'm sorry if I've said that wrong and it's a concept of emotional detachment from an outcome. Specifically Wikipedia tells us that it's in the Arabic language and it's the word for the Islamic concept of the reliance on God, of trusting in God's plans. It's seen as a perfect trust in God and
reliance on him alone and it can also be referred to as God consciousness. So I kind of like this idea regardless of whether you have faith in any God or any religion at all, I kind of like this idea, regardless of whether you have faith in any God or any religion at all. I kind of like this idea because it resonated with me for kind of thinking about our journey in psychology. And then there was also a comment on there that there was also a similar Hindu practice as well and it was Anirudh Zala who'd said that in Hinduism and probably every other religion as well he said there's a concept called Nishkama Karma and so I had a little google about that let me tell you about Nishkama Karma and it's the selfless or desireless action so when an action is performed without any expectation of fruits or results and of course this is particularly useful for us when we're thinking about the process of applying for jobs and applying for training places
this can be really tricky because, you know, we might well apply when we feel like we're ready, but we can't know who else is applying and, you know, what the calibre of other applicants might be. We have to hope that any recruitment processes are robust and valid. And of course, we just have to kind of trust in that process but you know sometimes people do get on to training courses on their first attempt and so I had a little look at some stats from the alternative handbook 2021 edition and people definitely do get on from first attempt. So from the respondents I looked at, I flicked through, you know, Bangor, East Anglia, East London, Edinburgh, Essex, Exeter and Hertfordshire.
That's the ones I flicked through. So 36%, 22%, 29%, 41%, 45%, 13%, 22%. This, of course, is only that percentage of applicants. And I noticed that there were no respondents for Coventry and Warwick. And it might be that there's other courses as well that had no representation. But I don't ever remember getting a survey and I do wonder I would like your opinion if you know that this is not true or even if it is true I do wonder if they only sample BPS members because I was only a BPS member I think for part of my first year so
it might be that I wasn't a member when they sampled. But yeah, it seems strange that there was no respondents for a whole course. So yeah, we can only really take this as being the opinion of some people, perhaps the opinion of people who are more likely to fill in surveys as well. So it might not necessarily be, you know, an accurate depiction. But so it tells us that some people do get on first time but what it doesn't tell us necessarily is you know what their career journey had been like before they applied and of course what their age might have been like and you know what they wrote on their form there can be many many different things that the the data doesn't tell us. But of course, I also quite enjoyed the fact that East London and Exeter and Hertfordshire
had respondents who got on sixth time lucky. So, you know, if you don't give up and you keep changing and you keep reflecting and you keep the faith and you keep changing and you keep reflecting and you keep the faith um and you keep applying in terms of the nishkama um karma and the tawakkal and i'm so sorry if that is um if you do speak arabic i've got that horrendously wrong please do let me know um and i will i'll do like a a tv reframe where i have to apologize and say the correct pronunciation so I did try and have a google but I couldn't find anyone that told me how to pronounce it properly
so um yeah if I've got that wrong um then do let me know but it's kind of like well I'm going to keep trying I'm going to keep bringing my best to the show um and you know when it's my time I will be successful and I honestly believe that when you get there when you get on to your professional when you get on to your professional doctoral course whichever discipline of psychology that might be that it won't matter how many times you've applied because I firmly believe you'll get on when you're ready and when the right time for you is because what I wouldn't want for you is for you to gain a place and feel massively out of your comfort zones and like everything feels overwhelming. Let's take a little short break here and I do think because of the time of year even though I haven't got my
Christmas tree up it might be time to switch to our slightly Christmassy jingle from the Aspiring Psychologist podcast so this was the original jingle and I said I love it but I do wonder if it sounds a little bit too like a Christmas edition so I would love your thoughts and your feedback on what you think to the Christmas version hope you enjoy it I would love your thoughts and your feedback on what you think to the Christmas version. Hope you for listening hoped you liked those lovely sleigh bells so um thank you for everyone who's been in contact recently pitching yourselves um for episodes of the podcast it's been really lovely to hear from so many of you but please keep those um contacts
coming if you think you've got a unique interesting or just useful tale to tell um about your journey to becoming a qualified psychologist um do get in contact with me um and let's get you uh let's have a let's have a chat to see whether it might make a good podcast episode um because i love hearing from you and i like it that people you know feel like this is also your show too because it is you know this is about you it's done with you and for you um so yeah we're aiming to get more and more aspiring psychologists in the show as well as themes and debates that you might find interesting and useful too um if you don't want to be in an episode which is absolutely understandable do please get in contact with ideas that you want to potentially feature and have me discuss
and I can then find a guest or I can just do it freestyle. So yeah very short and sweet episode today but I didn't want to leave you guys without an episode because I know that I've wound myself into a little Monday fabric of many of your lives and that is a wonderful privilege so thank you so much if you would welcome some more advice and support and guidance please consider coming along to the aspiring psychologist membership where we're doing lovely things and creating really nice group of people as well people are saying really nice things about it and it's helping them to develop their confidence and to feel supported especially if they don't feel supported in the workplace or if they haven't in the past so yeah if that describes you or if you just think that you could use with brushing up a bit on your
confidence and your skills in things like CBT reflective practice then come on board it'd be lovely to have you there otherwise do please come and join our free facebook group as well it is the aspiring psychologist community bracket free group um and that's with dr marianne trent i do believe um but yeah thank you so much for being part of my world and i will look forward to catching up with you very soon for our next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide
with this podcast that you'll start to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that
no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.